hello everybody hope that you're having
a nice weekend today it's Saturday and I
think it's going to be a new thing for
the channel a Saturday thing I think
last week we charted chain link and I
told you guys that if you wanted me to
chart any other altcoin you could
request the article in the comments
request so here I am charting your coin
now if you want me to chart another
alcohol mention in the comments and next
weekend next Saturday
another for example Solana polkadot does
requests so depending on what I see in
the comments of this video I might
charge those ones or a different one so
anyway guys Carden I think it's quite
interesting coin because in the previous
vulron
you did something
insane I remember in Market Capitals top
four top five I think the ranking was
Bitcoin ethereum BNB
cardano and then it was
um Teter usdt so did amazing and if you
see what happened here at the top was at
three dollars ten
and if you check the bottom this is mind
blowing look at this
one cent
one set from one cent it went to three
dollars ten it doesn't make any sense
I'm not saying that it's gonna happen
again obviously because also what we saw
at the top it was like a insane amount
of fomo but I did a 17
000 percent guys that's insane of course
I'm not saying that ADA is gonna do that
in the next version because that will
take you to
something like 50 60 dollars for enough
and I don't think that's possible
because the market cap needed for a move
like that it doesn't make any sense it's
it's almost impossible to be honest with
you so I want to keep your feet in the
ground okay uh we're gonna now have a
look at the liquidity pools that I can
see in the chart that they're gonna be
potential targets to the upside
also to the downside because you have
the question of
half altcoins bottom okay is is this the
bottom of cardano about 24p
I'm not sure about that so when I go
through the charts and see what they
tell us first things first let's start
to find imbalances you know from this
move from the top to the to the lows
um okay the imbalances that I can see so
far would be this candle here
okay
um this one over here
iotc are quite a long week here so let's
mark the 50 of it
okay that's around 220 and of course
this imbalance from the highs
and you can see that it's quite
interesting
the biggest imbalance that I can see in
the chart is at the highest
you know this imbalance is basically
what they are they are zones in the
chart that price is going to come back
to at some point we don't know when
obviously it'll be in the next Bull Run
what is the next problem it's difficult
to tell have you seen the bottom yet
but when I got through that in a minute
okay but these are the zones to the
upside the price is going to go to okay
I can tell you that pretty certain okay
now does this mean that it's gonna come
to this highs you know and that's one of
the top of course not because you know
guys how bull runes are I mean it's most
likely things that we see a new high uh
I'm not of course I'm not talking about
I'm not even I don't even thinking that
ten dollars is possible at this point to
be honest but I think that maybe four
dollars yeah around maybe four dollars
or three seventy I think that makes some
sense
5 volts is it quite far to be honest I
don't think
that either can go to five dollars in
the next Ballroom
I don't know it's just my opinion guys
uh but anyway if you happen to buy here
for example
and we go again to the highs you know
that's out of there
almost 700 percent now if you go to four
dollars that's a one thousand percent
but now you have to keep in mind that
there is a chance the price goes lower
we're gonna go through this now
but imagine the price goes back to 20
cents okay let's check now from 20 cents
20 cents to the highest again to three
dollars that's around one thousand three
hundred percent but if it goes to four
dollars that's one thousand and hundred
percent almost two thousand percent
that's double as if you buy now okay so
it's very important
to you know to have a plan I'm gonna
tell you what I think of course not
foreign
or even in this Zone as you want to DCA
yes why not you can DCA now but if you
haven't bought anything
you know you can rule out the scenario
that maybe this is this is not the
bottom maybe this is a lower price now
okay of course you could buy now if you
wanted to and then buy lower if you have
the opportunity all right but I'm gonna
show you why I think that it's likely
that we see new lows for cardano
I don't know if you guys know this chart
it's a total three this is the market
cap in crypto excluding Bitcoin and
ethereum so you only have altcoins and
stable coins okay and this is I I use
this when I when I chart a new altcoin
that have been charged for for months or
weeks
um I like to have a look at the total
three and compare it with the altcoin to
see if the ultimate is moving you know
according to this chart or if it's
moving in a different way or making
different moves so you can see that
cardeno
you know is making the same moves so
nothing really to point out here now if
we check the 50ma in the weekly time
frame this is what I meant if you're
here yes you can this here now but if
you haven't bought yet you have two well
three three options
to have the option of buying now and if
it goes lower you can DCA but I'll tell
you that this year lower is not really
my style I like to DCA as price goes up
okay this is what that's what I usually
do so really to me there are two options
now and is to buy after confirmation
you're gonna lose some appreciation of
price but you know that when you buy
it's not gonna go low one it's quite
safe for you to make money or you know
you can see and wait if we make new lows
that's the responsibility so let's see
what I mean about buying in confirmation
let's see what happened in the previous
World room this was 2020 right before
the ballroom and you can see the you
know we have the one or two cents
opportunity and then it made a move
above the 15 in the weekly time frame
you can see that here it was resistance
again resistance now push above the 50ma
come back to it tested a support and
then you can see price going higher so
that would be my confirmation to buy
this altcoin okay I would like to see
the same you know push High break above
the 50ma this is a support and that's
your buy Zone okay so yes of course if
you don't buy now and price goes high
from here then you're gonna miss summer
Precision in price but I mean it's not
that much from 38p to around 48p 49p
it's not that much written here you're
gonna have the security and the
confidence that price is going to go
higher so do you have an opinion on
these options as to to buy
in confirmation or we're gonna go now
through the scenario that is what about
if price hasn't bottomed yet
we're on the Bitcoin dominance chart
we've been stuck in this range for two
years now and basically you can see the
price has been going up down up down up
and many people here are currently for a
North system because they were expecting
price to go down this is technically
wrong because these drops are not old
systems okay this is announced season
here let me show you
in 2021 beautiful time for crypto uh
this was another season okay but you can
compare these moves the difference is
like three four times the the size of
the drop okay so this would only be you
know altcoin rallies but not all season
now you can see that this time
it's looking a bit different than the
previous time because usually what we
see is a week and price gets rejected
again
to the low of the range but this time it
seems like you know we haven't got a
rejection yesterday after the Scandal
we've gone back to it above it okay and
now we are doing so kind of
consolidation here
in resistance so what about if we see
the Bitcoin dominance breaking out you
know do something like this
to 52 53 percent that would
wrecked the altcoin market I can tell
you that that would destroy altcoins
um if you compare this cycle this bear
Market with other bear markets in the
past
I remember the in previous bear markets
literally you could see 90 of altcoins
projects disappearing
have you seen that in this cycle
not really so that makes me think
that maybe we haven't reached the bottom
in the altcoin market maybe maybe the
Bitcoin dominance breaks out and which
says some kind of a big dump in altcoins
okay
and this reminds me of what happened
back in 2018
because I remember that here we saw the
Bitcoin dominance going up and Bitcoin
going up
um alkins were taking a you know quite a
dump here I would say let's check this
total three again uh
um I mean yes you can see the from here
okay the Bitcoin dominance was going up
and the altcoins was going were going
down you can see now
the interesting part about this is that
then
Bitcoin went down
and the Bitcoin dominance held this one
and didn't go down
and this time it was when the altcoin
market
crashed and I'm telling you crashed
because it went from 67 billion
dollars market cap to 30 billion dollars
market cap so that was
fifty percent in the 50 drop in the
total free remember that there are also
some stable concierge so really it's not
fifty percent for all good it's more
like maybe like a 55 60 drop now I'm not
saying that this is going to happen
again okay I'm not talking about 60 drop
from here in altcoin's ball you know if
Bitcoin dominance breaks Above This
resistance
and we go to 52 53 percent
I think the outcomes are not gonna do
well
now if we go to the cardano versus
Bitcoin chart
you want to see that is not looking
bullish at all because we keep making
new lows so the most likely thing in my
opinion is that we see a new low in the
cardano versus Bitcoin chart
because Bitcoin is outperforming
altcoins
okay that's what the Bitcoin dominance
keeps going up so if we see something
like this for the Bitcoin dominance
chart you know flipping this resistance
into support
I think we're gonna go probably to 52
and 53 percent and in this one here
if Bitcoin goes down
and the Bitcoin dominance holds I'm by
going down I'm saying to the Bitcoin
goes to new low so I'm saying that
Bitcoin maybe goes to 25k 22k at the
same time because timing is very
important that the Bitcoin dominance
flips this resistance into support and
holds this Zone
then we're gonna see a big dump in
altcoins
I know if the title of the video said
something like Carolina might go to five
dollars it might explode soon
I will get more use but what's the point
guys I'm a Trader so as a Trader have to
be prepared for anything to happen and
that's why I make my own plans
I don't know in cardan at the moment if
you do
of course you can DCA that's a valid
strategy but I don't and my plan is
either to buy a confirmation that will
be a retest of the weekly 50ma
or
to see if we can see something like this
happening okay that would be the Bitcoin
dominance
to flip this resistance into support or
maybe go higher to 52 53 percent that
would bring altcoins down or if the
timing is perfect and we flip this
resistance into support and we hold here
for the Bitcoin dominance while Bitcoin
goes down maybe to 25k 22k then again
you're gonna see a victim for altcoins
so let's go now to the chart of ADA
versus the dollar and see what bisons
but I'm fine
we are back in the cardano chart and we
Mark the imbalances to the upstairs so
they are going to be take profits areas
okay and I want to maximums to the
downside in case we see the second
scenario that I story about of the
Bitcoin dominance
um playing out okay so you can see in
the monthly time frame you can see
pretty clear double cardano was doing
here was
retracing this liquidity pool in the
left between 34 cents and 18 cents okay
and you can see that now it has already
retraced about I would say 60 percent of
this liquidity pool but why not why
couldn't it retrace the other
40 okay and that would be this Zone here
okay let me Mark it for you
between
24 cents okay that's a previous loan and
18 cents okay I mean it's all it seems
like it's already retracing this this
liquid pool now if you don't if you see
cardano can't break this Zone Above This
Zone
okay you can see that it's been it's
been the resistance for qualm time even
all the way here and here was support to
be honest so you can see that this was a
support Zone that now has become
resistance so if we see you know a push
down again
and this lows don't hold they're gonna
see cardano going to this area all the
way to 18 cents now if we go to the
weekly time frame let's see if we can
see the same
okay in the weekly time frame
uh what let me remove this because in
the weekly time frame you can see
an imbalance in this Zone here
and another imbalance below
okay
and if I extend this here
I want to say the you want to see this
more clear
you have an imbalance between 23 cents
and 21 cents and another imbalance
between 19 cents and 16 cents so yeah I
think like the monthly timeframe was I
think more clear of course you could go
if he breaks you know below this Zone
I think that the main target I'm gonna
be keeping an eye on should be 18 cents
but I could also go the way to 16
Central I don't know first of course you
have to see how it's going to react in
the wiki time frame you can see the same
here this was support now it's
resistance if it doesn't break below it
or it doesn't break above the 50ma and
Tesla support
then the most likely thing is that
cardano goes back to this lows and if
they don't hold then we are going to see
18 cents now imagine for a moment that
if we uh if we buy a 18 cents
let me check this for you
if we buy 18 cents okay and it goes
again all the way to to this
um quite a big liquidity pool that I
think price is gonna go there yes or yes
that's a 1 500 percent up that's insane
okay this is what I mean guys uh of
course again if this idea gets
invalidated and we see
price breaking above the weekly 50ma
test the support then I'm buying in this
Zone okay I'm a buyer here and then from
here
to again do size
that would be uh almost 500 percent is
three times less but still that's a
times five I will be pretty happy okay
so that's that's the chart that I have
now in man that's my plan for Colorado I
hope that you like the video guys and
I'll see you soon